anyway look let's let's let's go to
something a little more soothing if you
don't mind okay
so is this it this is the background now
yeah trump's gone but our problems
aren't
she just settled on this background this
is her this isn't her youtube show this
is a little late with lily yeah
oh wait no that's the show this is the
show now no no no no we've been watching
her show this isn't a youtube video so
she has an nbc
youtube show yes okay that makes sense
he's no longer the president of the
united states
donald trump is no longer the president
of the united states so
moments like this i wish i had a live
audience because i know that that would
have gotten the biggest applause that
i'll ever get
and then even if it didn't we would just
use applauses from another episode
yeah but you know what the other thing
but i see lilly
you could call me pet pepperidge farm
because i remember
i remember when this show started your
first season you made it very clear that
you said
our show's not going to be political
remember that we talked about it on the
show
we just want to make people laugh y'all
our show's not going to be political
we're not going to take shots at any
political side
we're just going to have fun what
happened is you realize your show sucked
anyway
and now you're trying to see if your
second season if you jump on the
political bandwagon if
that'll get people to watch you i mean
they're still not because you're
inherently not funny
but that what happened to that whole
world this isn't a political show we're
just going to have fun oh that's over
now isn't it lily
i wish i had a live audience because i
know that that would have gotten the
biggest applause that i'll ever get now
okay hold on let me address something i
know once upon a time i said you know on
my show i'm not going to be political
but when i said what did i just say
what did i just say what did i just say
but
i said you know on my show i'm not going
to be political but when i said that
i meant like i'm not going to address
the minutia of like the latest pork
barrel spending legislation obviously i
don't know what that is one of my
writers wrote it because i'm just like
why would you be spending money on pork
rails
that's not my fortune wait wait a minute
so you started off by
saying i'm not gonna do a thing that
nobody would ever think you would have
done on a late night comedy show anyway
like hey there's one thing we're not
gonna do on this late night talk show is
discuss
each and every bill going through
congress on every gate no when you said
i'm not going to get all political you
were like nah we're going to have a fun
time
yeah that's not where you failed at the
comedy and now you're like well now we
got to find
a way to get back to the political stuff
but also find a way where i'm not a liar
but you're a liar that's not that's no
no no no
you say you're a liar we've watched this
since the very inception on this show we
watched and
we're day one we that is not how you
meant it
that's not how you said it you [ __ ]
lied
you're lying now and you're realizing
that man all these are the people making
fun of trump and that seems to work for
them
you'll be spending money on pork rails
that's not my forte i don't know
but i feel like these things are not
really political things right they're
literally the most you're talking about
a president
that's literally the most political
thing you could do
i love to see her mental gymnastics
they're kind of more like human things
and they're too big to ignore
like inauguration i feel like now that
trump is gone
you know human guys you know human
things little things that make us human
like the presidential inauguration not
politics what
they're too big to ignore like
inauguration i feel like now that trump
is gone it's a bright day for all of us
you feel me not if you're somebody that
pays taxes
seriously [ __ ] not if you're somebody
that pays taxes
or works in the enter in the [ __ ] oil
industry especially you
oval office chair you made it little guy
with all the negatives the president did
i do want to highlight the one
positive thing donald trump did there
was one step forward for equality and
that is
that white people are now finally
referred to as terrorists
finally
finally referred to as terrorists she
wasn't gonna be politic remember
she wasn't gonna be political but wait a
minute what about
uh timothy mcveigh what about the ira
what about the ted kazoo
well ted kaczynski um the
cr what is it the christian identity
movement uh
what about all that stuff lily i mean
white people have been
called terrorists white people kind of
invented terrorism like white people
were technically the first people to
ever go like
you know we could just run and park the
car and then we don't have to die
we could just go get a really unassuming
looking old mercury grand marquis
and load that thing with or an rv
like why people do have a tenant like
since when have white people
never been considered terrorists finally
referred to as terrorists
it took four long painful years but he
did it now i know a lot of people
yeah trump ted trump saving listen uh
again not happy with trump but trump not
starting a new war
trump making sure that pulling 18 and 19
year olds out of the middle east so they
don't get their arms and legs blown off
the right to triax or people that have
cancer could try none of those were good
things
the only good thing for you is that
white people were hurt
hey lily you know most of the people
that watch your youtube videos are white
girls right
you know that people are gonna say stop
talking about trump and people just
don't want to hear about it anymore
and i get it having said that having
said that
i don't care what people think or what
they want or what they want to see on tv
i'm going to do what i want and fail at
it well if they did her ratings would
have better than carson daly's
good it's important to acknowledge that
just because trump is gone
it doesn't mean all of our old problems
are also gone we still have a lot of
healing to do we have a lot of work to
do and i do think that's important to
talk about
and the first step to healing is by
calling all white people terrorists and
and saying they look like
child molesters that that's a crowd
that's how you heal it's time to heal
you that's what i can heal pieces of
[ __ ] that's exactly that's exactly what
she's doing
deal with racism right a lot of people
like to point out that trump is the
symbol for racism and yeah sure he
encouraged white supremacists but in
terms of a symbol for racism
let's not forget about encourage white
supremacists by giving more money to
israel and moving the [ __ ]
moving the embassy to jerusalem yeah
you're right it's like you just
the platinum plan the platinum plan was
him encouraging white supremacists
shut up you guys are basically like ted
bundy pulling some poor girl into a van
them and then shooting them and then
while they're laying there dead go
look it's it's time for us to heal okay
it's time for us to heal and move on and
maybe you take some time to think about
why you're dressed that way
but it's time for us to move on and heal
we can't just sit here and dwell on this
in a van and this subsequent murder like
you guys are [ __ ]
literally the aggressors and then you're
like yeah but seriously i think it's
time that we all stop being so
aggressive
action jackson has a good point maybe
she maybe she meant heal like h-e-e-l
maybe it's time to be the heel i mean
yeah
but what was it again plantations
because can we just be real
just be real i don't know what a
plantation is y'all like i speak like a
black person even though i'm from
toronto
and i'm indian dog yeah what a homie and
i've been trying to tone down my black
voice but when i get excited sometimes i
still can't i mean dawg look at my first
see some other videos homie
what up dog what you're doing lily sing
is a million times more insulting
than anything you're going against
you're putting on
a minstrel show you're putting on a
minstrel
show and you're not even black i feel
like she probably
has to be aware of a lot of this stuff
and she's got to be
just living in a [ __ ] one thing i
look forward to
by the way is watching lily sing
age poorly and she's going to because
all of this [ __ ] is eating her up inside
the the fact that she still doesn't even
know what she is
and the fact that she's willing to be
whatever it is that will get her
more people to what like she's she is
definitely living in a self-created
[ __ ] hell world and it's going to be
fun watching her spiral
because she is going to spiral this
woman's going to fall apart
it's gonna be fantastic racism's been
here okay and to quote the freshest of
princes will smith he says
racism isn't getting worse it's just
getting filmed but hey at least
well no he also said haha my wife made a
cuck out of me yeah
it's true now everyone knows you know
what else will smith said
he says you better fire that to place my
aunt in the show where i'm not [ __ ]
coming back here again
and then you made it so no will smith
also made it so nobody would work with
this lady
and she was actually a professionally
trained actress he made it so
nobody would work with this lady at all
he completely scorched her career
but what he made he made getting jiggy
with it that is true
when you do read the stories that woman
was a [ __ ] [ __ ] though
she really okay what he did was wrong
like he took it to a level it didn't
need to go
but by all accounts that woman was a
[ __ ]
we can start working on anti-racist
principles and that includes having a
lot of really tough conversations you
know with your mom
your dad your aunt your uncle listen
yeah ruin your family relationships
hey little girls little girls and boys
that watch lily sing on the youtubes
ruin all of your family relationships
because some [ __ ]
dumb from toronto just told you to that
makes sense
about sex in front of millions of people
including my indian parents and i just
got goosebumps right now then you can
turn off fox news
and say hmm maybe i should get my first
black friend or latina friend or a gay
friend or the
that's right you guys don't know any
black people yeah people that watch fox
news don't have black friends apparently
i'm unaware of this did you know that
what happened to all the black and
hispanic people you called white
supremacists
i'm cuban you called you called me a
white supreme white supremacist and i'm
cuban
i mean you said you said i was
the friend that says i'm just gonna
carry a reusable tote bag just in case
that's the kind i have a black friend
you guys actually called him an uncle
tom and doxed him
and i don't get to see him on twitter
yeah you're right that's a really good
point that's a really good point
the way we gotta heal is we gotta
rebuild the trust between a lot of
americans and science
and facts especially the press because
when i think of scientists
i think of people than lap coats and
lily sing
because right now they're not talking
and we gotta face it there's gonna be a
lot of people who will never accept
facts that they disagree with just like
how i will not accept the nutritional
information on the back of a frozen
pizza box
the sodium is your opinion or if or you
will never accept fbi crime stats either
i mean
we're gonna we're gonna talk about
people not accepting stats
yeah gotta elect better leaders with
better values which is tough because no
you don't want better leaders or better
values you want leaders that pander to
you and make you
make your fifi feel good that's what you
want you want people to pay
you so you don't want you don't want
nobody really wants leadership
okay and i'm talking about the left or
the right and i think you'll agree with
this nobody really
wants leadership most people in 2021
want people to pat their head tell them
they're good
and tell them no no no no you guys are
bad but you guys are doing it right
that's what you want you want to be
pandered honestly that's not even that
that's not even it because i like that's
that wouldn't even be that bad
like being pandered to and just being
told you're good wouldn't be
toxic enough to be this cancerous on
society the problem is is that
it's not enough to just be patted on the
head and told you're good you need to be
told you're good and that all of them
are bad
yeah and that you're better than them
and there's nothing to be there's
nothing wrong with being painted there's
nothing wrong with going somewhere where
people appreciate you and go you're a
good dude
that's fine that's harmless but the
problem is it's not enough for us
everybody wants to be told you're good
and those people are bad and those
people are the reason why
all the things you don't like are
happening and you can go yeah
and that's the problem is everybody
wants somebody to blame and feel better
then and it's just [ __ ] ridiculous
now there are literally so many
republicans in the wings waiting to take
donald trump's position
one of them is literally named donald
trump no so all the so what you're
saying is you want unity and you want
but all republicans are bad
all so i'm sorry i'm trying to
understand here so you don't want to get
political this whole rant is political
and all republicans waiting in the wings
are bad and evil people
all of them every single one of them are
bad and every single democrat is good
that's how we we're not judging people
based on the individual things that
they're doing or stuff like that
we're judging them on what party are you
great job lily
great job no not to mention all the
serious problems we need to deal with
that trump made way worse like climate
change
climate change our actual co2 emissions
are the lowest of any
any country in the world right now
corporate greed institutional racism
corporate greed corporate greed which uh
in silicon valley is going to get even
bigger under biden because he hired
people
from these mega corporations like google
and amazon to be in his cabinet
yeah by the way i work for this little
known company called rotc
uh media who do you work for though oh
uh well nbc which is owned by comcast
and well it's a joint venture actually
it's comcast and who's the other company
too
well it used to be owned by ge well it
still is it's ge is ge and comcast own a
joint venture that owns nbc
so ge comcast nbc universal
it's like you you work for these people
i
don't you do you work for them some
unflattering white shorts all serious
issues
also can i just point out to wear shorts
like that the irrational confidence i
just
could you imagine body shaming a [ __ ]
uh
a leftist and how [ __ ] you you
imagine body shaming kamala harris
these people don't live by their own of
course they don't live by their own
rules of course they don't she's allowed
to body shame people
but if you make fun of lily singh you
could call the misogynistic pig
because she's [ __ ] she's lily singh
is
built the way an 80 suit looks
fever and positives and silver linings
and i believe that now that we see all
these problems laid out before us we can
do
something about them they're no longer
hidden and we can speak up
and call out hate when we see it it's
all of our jobs okay cool can i call out
hate
why do you hate white people so much why
do you hate republicans so much
why do you hate why do you call them all
you're [ __ ] other people on your
little peacock network
call them child molesters and white
supremacists without
any facts why do they be put on no fly
list
which i mean i get it because baked
alaska
does kind of look like a child molester
but that he was the only one that i saw
there that kind of looked like one
the rest of them all just looked like
idiots
i'm still working on the second or third
but luckily i have 73 more episodes to
figure it out so stand by
so yeah 73 more episodes
73 more so they did
73. they can't get rid of her she's
they're stuck with her for the same
reason
this is why back in the day people
didn't like hiring them
because you get [ __ ] stuck with them
when they want to cry about racism or
misogyny
and you can never fire them they're
unfireable
we have a lot to do but yo one giant
orange roadblock is out of the way so
good dog i ain't gonna talk about
politics dog except my ratings are down
homie you hear me
skirt skirt so now i'm gonna be [ __ ]
talking about politics dude
[ __ ] shut up you disingenuous stupid
no one gives a [ __ ] about you you don't
want to [ __ ] talk about hate
you just want to [ __ ] talk about the
things that you you don't even believe
you're right don't you believe in half
the [ __ ] that you're saying anyway
you're just pandering to your [ __ ]
youtube audiences that's all you're
doing
ugh [ __ ] disgusting